he's funny he's talented he has many
many cars even though none of us have
anywhere to go
right okay he's the host of Jay Leno's
Garage which you can watch Wednesday's
on CNBC I am talking about the one and
only Jay Leno
are you there Jay I'm right here hey
Kelly good you look sharp
how do you stow it this shark look at me
I look like I'm going to a volleyball
game and you look like you're about to
host the show again that's what happens
when you have a little tiny postage
stamp iPhone thing everybody looks good
all right well we were actually just
talking about quarantine gardening do
you guys do I guard you know I tried
between the mulch the fertilizer the
garden tools I realized it's costing
about 1,500 bucks of tomato and I
realized okay well this is because you
know there's really no really no
vegetable shortage I mean there's plenty
of produce
there's no reason people are panic like
that you know so no I have to say no the
garden thing did not work out in my face
no I think the thing that Reed was
talking to us earlier about was it he
just had some older family members as
well he didn't really want going to the
grocery store see it was like trying he
asked a farmer and his name is Jacob the
farmer and he gave his produce away for
free just to like pay it for and it was
really really sweet and anyway i-i've
only garden once I actually nailed it
but it just is so time-consuming
I don't know plus I'm more of a
carnivore so if anybody's got an extra
cow they don't want you know well I'm on
a ranch so we've got plenty of those
brother stuff no we're not going hungry
here all right well how is quarantine
going because I know that you know you
and I are both people are used to being
on the road so as like being stuck at
home or really how hard is it for your
wife having you around that much I mean
I know sort of a quarantine life I come
home every night when I'm on the road
almost no matter where I am unless I'm
unless then pass a Mississippi River
anything west Mississippi I just come
home every night so it's really not a
huge change for me plus I'm not a
networks I'm I never explained
ever complain kind of guy you know I
don't like you said you and I have both
very fortunate to be in this business
and we both doing okay so we don't have
to be out there hustling so yeah I can't
say it's it's it's been terrible it's
okay yeah no that's I always try and
keep perspective you know at all times
but um are you optimistic about how all
this is gonna play out or what are you
yes I am you know because I saw this
doctor foul Qi guy on TV and he said yes
the war we have to fight it like a wall
and then a reporter says well how do me
that he says by staying home and
watching television I thought well if
there's any war Americans uniquely
qualified I mean I have been training
for this my whole life
I sit home and watch TV how hard is that
and then I saw like some dopey celebrity
I won't say who it is I saw him on the
show and he said you know I feel like a
prisoner of war in my own home I want
okay but you know this is the first
conflict in history where the prisoners
of war are fatter at the end okay
okay there's nobody nobody starving to
death here well and it's funny cuz I
have seen things I won't mention
anything either because I know people
are just trying to distract people and
it's you know what they're just trying
to do their own thing but it's funny
because I'm like no one wants to see a
celebrity and they're really nice house
like being like I'm so trapped like
that's right I'm a huge believer and low
self-esteem I I believe that if you
don't think you're the smartest person
in the room you'll shut up and you
listen and that's what I try to I don't
want to keep it by I mean I used to love
those things and I think nbcnbc stuff
doesn't we wanted you to know and they
would have some set of ego food give it
to your kids they'll like it you know I
thank you thank you very much cuz I know
as a comedian you must be how are you
trying out your jokes are you trying
them out on me this you can't hit this
is it I'm here I'm talking to you babes
I thought I slipped a couple in there I
saw you laughs I said okay I guess
they're working state they are working
your toes around on me because it is you
see how a lot of celebrities are like I
guess read today
Jesse Smollett he actually paid to beat
him up you laugh but you giggle oh
that's terrible and then laugh it did
yeah I think you can be equally offended
and also laughs what I love I mean
people when people especially if they're
making fun of me man if it's a good one
I laugh with you if it's like funny
I'm like a bear for it like on the news
that a tiger at the Bronx Zoo has this
coronavirus and that shows how ahead of
the curve I've always been because I
always try to keep six feet between me
and a tiger so if I see a tiger I try to
have that barrier and I would have
walked up and just hugged it yeah that's
right that's right
luckily people are giving us his
distance message thank you for saving
their lives
there are tips like they said the corona
virus can live on plastic for up to
three days so we're in Beverly Hills
don't touch the women y'all stocked up
did you go to the store and just stock
up
well we go to this you know it's so
funny I went to the Browns market right
down the street here right near our
where where we'll be both use it to our
show and they have a thing where if
you're over 60 you go to the front of
the line so I'm standing in line you
know on a few line and the security
guard goes say slowly you're over 60
right oh yeah well I'm seven he goes
well you go to find the line okay great
so as I'm walking the hey people go
celebrity goes bit so now I now I start
limping like now I'm limping as I'm
walking you know to get some sympathy oh
go ahead you don't like it I feel like
that
remember the guy in the Titanic to put
on the dress and get a lifeboat so I
sneak into rels like this ya know we're
pretty stocked up
alright well are you enjoying quality
time with me miss because I know that
there are times that I want to strangle
my husband so no I'm not sure we get
along good you know we've manageable
you know the funny thing about being
married for 40 years you get a rhythm
thing going yeah like I don't understand
these like I don't know what I would do
in the 25 row like my wife and I when
this thing started well let's watch a
movie watch something on Netflix I fall
asleep about halfway through she fall
asleep a little bit later the movie ends
I go honey what happened
I don't know watch tomorrow great you
know I never understood why my parents
watch the same Matlock over and over
again yeah but now I do now I get it now
I understand why oh I see they fall
asleep before the end and they have to
watch the whole thing all over again so
it's actually okay oh well we're a
younger couple Danielle so we are we've
definitely wanted to kill each other at
some point but um but we will aim for
your status there you go alright well
have you been getting out on Drive still
like you're using your all those cars
you know I'm here in my garage right now
this thing behind me is called the 3d
printer we use it to make parts when I
work on cars but he's doing it we've
been making these masts and we make them
for free and we the machine runs 24
hours a day we got a couple of them here
and we turn out these masks we just make
this part this plastic part another guy
makes this part and you sort of put them
on like this you know like you would
want and we give me free we just make
them afraid just turn them out all day
we give them to the fire department they
give them the first responders so you
feel like you're doing something yeah I
always tell people maybe you got old
blankets maybe got things you can give
to the goodwill I mean everybody can do
something to help out a little bit and
that's kind of what we're doing I mean I
enjoy working on my cars but this
machine doesn't make parts all the time
so what we do is you just read the last
two or three weeks you've had it running
this is all the spare pieces here and we
this is what they look like that's so
cool and and we just we bang these out
and we give them the first responders
and who else where we want something
that's really cool and I know you said
it makes you feel good and ever feel
like you're helping me you are helping
that's a really incredibly cool thing
you could be like you said you could
just be like a lot of Americans are
sitting at home watching TV and eating
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going